cercherò di analizzare con voi oggi le
ragioni e le responsabilita a base di un
lavoro giornalistico in particolare un
giornalismo fatto con immagini cercherò
di comunicarvi l'importanza di una
coscienza individuale una coscienza
sociale per il miglioramento e la
società tutte queste queste riflessioni
porta una delle domande del domande che
io in questo momento mi sto ponendo e
porlo anche a voi durante questo talk
nel 2008 ho deciso di lasciare il lavoro
di ingegnere del telecomunicazione
barcellona e di provare a dedicarmi alla
passione che era la fotografia e dopo un
paio deve portare se in iran in turchia
cominciato a documentare la breaking
news e sono andato in abruzzo che nel
mio paese di origine per coprire il
grande sisma dell'aquila
inizialmente ho collaborato come sperano
l'agenzia come ha fatto un contratto un
contratto come sta photographer ho
lavorato circa un paio di anni dove ho
fatto gavetta praticamente ho cercato di
imparare il lavoro le tecniche
comprendere come funziona l'editoria
come funzionano i quotidiani nazionali
internazionali magazine
ad un certo punto dal 2011 scoppiano le
primavere arabe queste guerre
rivoluzioni nel bacino del medio oriente
baccin al mentre anni o in africa dove
documentato prima nella zona est del
paese
poi sono andato a tripoli e infine a
sirte dove c'è stata l'ultima battaglia
la battaglia per la fine della guerra
dove è stato preso e dove è stato ucciso
dove c'è stato ucciso gheddafi
in quel momento ho scattato questa
immagine questa fotografia che
rappresenta una delle prove appunto
della fine della dittatura
dopo negli anni successivi sono stato in
iraq e rosa va in sudan dove che il
paese più giovane al mondo dove c'è un
grande scontro fra le diverse etnie dopo
che sono andato ad haiti dove
documentato questa grande violazione del
team ha né in un centro psichiatrico e
poi sono finito in siria il più grande
conflitto contemporaneo dove il frisé
lean armi lotta contro l'esercito
l'esercito regolare di assad
questo lavoro insieme ad altri lavori
sono state riconosciute a livello
internazionale da grandi premi come la
robert capa e in questo momento io mi
sentivo come partecipe di
un'informazione necessaria come artefice
di un immagine di un'iconografia
fondamentale appunto per la presa di
coscienza della società
parallelamente alla mia carriera se non
hanno cominciato a sbocciare me diverse
domande diverse domande sulla
funzionalità effettiva del giornalismo
la funzionalità della fotografia i tipi
di strumenti che noi utilizziamo in
questo in queste fra queste domande la
domanda che mi viene quotidianamente
giorno dopo giorno è la seguente tanta
fotografia ho sempre pensato potesse
portare tanta informazione
quindi tanta presa di coscienza mi sono
reso conto che probabilmente questo
lemma può essere messo in discussione
ovvero tanta fotografia porta davvero
tante
informazione o rischia di portare una
strutturazione una saturazione delle
informazioni e un'apatia da parte del
fruitore dell'immagine o del frutto re
dell'informazione medesima con questa
domanda possiamo considerare un esempio
una fotografia nota nota ai più questo
bambino curdo siriano morto sulle
spiagge tour che nei pressi di bodrum
alan curvi tagore fotografia
effettivamente ha toccato la gente ha
toccato la gente ha toccato l'opinione
pubblica ha toccato addirittura le
agende dei politici dopo dopo l'ancor di
diverse persone uomini donne e bambini
non sono riuscite a finire al loro
viaggio e ahimè anche loro sono sono
morti e altre fotografie sono state
pubblicate quindi la domanda che mi
viene spontanea è questa fotografia ha
davvero toccato le coscienze questa
fotografia e riesce davvero a farci
prendere atto di quello che sta
succedendo perché le altre fotografie
sono passate nell'oblio soprassedere
dimenticatorio nel 2015 come altri
colleghi come molti dei fotografi
ho deciso di documentare questo grande
esodo l'esodo dei migranti e profughi di
questa nascita di un nuovo popolo gente
che scappa dalla guerra o dalla fame per
seguire un sogno quel lavoro
parallelamente era cominciato nel 2011
in parte coprivo le cause di queste
guerre rivoluzioni e in parte le
conseguenze sulla popolazione civile
ad un certo punto per chiudere il lavoro
fatto negli ultimi cinque anni e
cominciare la pubblicazione di un libro
ho deciso andare in macedonia macedonia
per seguire la rotta balcanica
ero in un treno un treno che dalla
grecia attraverso macedonia arriva la
serbia per poi portare i migranti in
europa questo treno stava documentando
le evidenze le prove di questa gente di
come vive di come sente di quello che
sta facendo del loro viaggio insomma ad
un certo punto mi sono reso conto tutte
queste domande hanno cominciato a
prendere più forza
secondo che stavo praticamente
documentando quello che era già stato
documentato stavo seguendo uno
stereotipo in un'immagine fotografie che
erano già state pubblicate ed erano già
state pubblicate da me medesimo quindi è
un certo punto arriva la notte scende la
notte queste persone cominciano a
dormire e mi rendo conto che prima di
essere migranti e profughi prima di
essere lo stereotipo dei migranti
profughi sono esseri umani sono come io
dormiente o voi dormienti i vostri amici
dormienti
quindi ho deciso di cominciare un
reportage di ritratti in modo più
empatico avvicinarmi a questa gente di
contestualizzarle dalle loro ragione o
delle loro dalle idee di profughi che
noi abbiamo su di loro ma cercare di
spiegare da un punto di vista umano
con queste idee è nato il progetto the
dream un viaggio emozionale sulla
ragione sull'intimità delle dei migranti
e dei profughi
parallelamente mi sono reso conto che
alla fotografia potevano essere
accompagnate altre forme d'arte sempre
per arrivare al punto finale quindi
all'obiettivo dell'informazione toccare
le coscienze
quindi ho pensato a una ibridazione
della fotografia magari con altre forme
d'arte con altre collaborazioni con
altri linguaggi un gruppo di difesa e di
di makers ha creato per il progetto
questa macchinetta una macchina europei
che la pillolina una scatoletta con un
buco un ring dentro alla luce entra
impressiona il rullino questa immagine
crea questa macchina fotografica crea
delle immagini dalla sono delle peters
delle prove non sono immagini
esattamente fotogiornalisti che voglia
sapere cosa succede siria ok le
fotografie visto prima spiegano la
storia queste sono immagini più i piloti
che sono immagini fuori dal tempo
immagini fuori dallo spazio
immagini che ti esprimono un sentimento
e ti ricordano un qualcosa ad esempio in
questa famiglia può essere è una
famiglia di migranti di profughi siriani
però potremmo essere tranquillamente
e noi dopo la seconda guerra mondiale o
i profughi e migranti del balcanici
della guerra nei balcani
quindi tutte le domande che mi sono
fatto prendevano sempre più forza sempre
più potere
ad un certo punto continuando sul
discorso della liberalizzazione
ho deciso di cercare delle
collaborazioni nelle collaborazioni
diverse ad esempio sono stato a lesbos
dove con un gruppo di migranti
abbiamo deciso di lavorare di progettare
a disegnare questa questa borsa la borsa
che conterrà libro questa borsa è stata
fatta da dai migranti medesime con i
giubbotti salvagente che i profumi
grandi appunto hanno usato per
attraversare il mar egeo ed arrivare in
europa un pezzo di storia insomma quindi
a domanda fondamentali continuano a
saltarmi in testa e la fotografia il
fotogiornalismo classico quello che
cerca di creare nelle con è lo strumento
fondamentale che oggigiorno in questa
società con questa della città di
informazione con il digitale sempre più
potente sempre più presente
parallelamente ho pensato ho visto
fondamentale
un'analisi continua un'analisi continua
e una riflessione costante su tutte
queste domande e ho deciso di unirmi con
un gruppo di fotogiornalisti i
videomaker professionisti e fondare una
cooperativa una copertina si chiama memo
inizialmente una cooperativa formata da
un gruppo di persone è diventata
immediatamente una community un network
di professionisti che si interrogano
giornalmente su questo tipo di domande
una community fatta da free lance per i
freelance i freelance sono quelle
persone che proprio rischio ea proprie
spese ea proprio pericolo decidono di
andare in delle zone che possono essere
di guerra o meno per raccontare i fatti
bene queste figure sono i creatori di
gran parte delle informazioni che oggi
torna noi vediamo sui quotidiani
magazine a livello internazionale
memo si interroga quotidianamente su
tutte queste domande e cerca l'obiettivo
finale è creare appunto un'informazione
che funziona un'informazione che porta
ai mille e una migliore del mondo
un'informazione che portano tutte la
lingua democrazia dei diritti umani
su queste basi questa community si fa
tante domande
alcune di queste domande le voglio le
voglio rivolgere a voi oggi mi lascerò
conte l'interrogativo che come
giornalista cerco di creare delle
interrogativi non ora risposte sono un
formatore che cerca di formare e quindi
sono domande aperte domande che risulta
che siano fondamentali per una crescita
una crescita e ripeto individuale e una
crescita comune bene oggi nel mondo ci
sono più di 35 guerre
abbiamo il dovere di raccontarle tutte
ma come farlo senza rendere il pubblico
saturo o addirttura patico in un mondo
dove le notizie sono sempre più veloci
volatili stiamo usando i migliori
strumenti in nostro possesso per davvero
riflettere e prendere coscienza sugli
avvenimenti oggi una parte sempre più
consistente come vi dicevo prima
dell'informazione viene creata viene
fatta dai free lance
come facciamo a tutelare il loro lavoro
la loro sicurezza per permettere loro di
continuare a portare un'informazione
indipendente al fine di una libertà di
espressione di stampa ma soprattutto
vogliamo davvero sapere cosa c'è succede
lì fuori uscire dalla nostra comfort
zone e prenderci le responsabilità sul
destino del mondo grazie